mike est ce que tu te sens de refaire
une autre une nouvelle émission de télé
ou pas savoir faire des trucs ou pas
ouais je pense que si on bat bat toi et
moi avec toi je vais au dessus même si
tu me faire confiance je te fais quoi
moi je te fais confiance
par contre toi me fait pas confiance en
[Applaudissements]
moi je te fais confiance et non mais
est-ce que tu serais prêt sans rien
voler est-ce qu'on est ce que tu serais
prêt faire un prime avec moi sur ces
huit tàu bien t on et étape à tapas de
tu peux travailler sur tout les gens et
je peux travailler avec qui je veux je
garde la liberté dans la vie je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui vaut une
fortune
eh bien tu veux pas qu'on fasse un truc
ensemble ouais c'est vrai que c'est
comment on pourrait faire quoi tous les
dons par comme ça non mais on va
réfléchir un peu à quoi moitié ce que
j'aimerais où nous la chute d'un
hélicoptère on sait pas où on est et on
se débrouille ouais tu veux qu'on fasse
ça mais ça c'est facile
ouais ça c'est non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on n'a pas d'argent on n'a rien rien on
n'a pas d'argent on a pas on n'a même
pas un nom n'a rien on n'a rien on va
tous les deux et on sait pas on joue la
femme ça et aussi cette religion qu ils
disent que vous j'ai peur des perdu tout
ça mais moi je sais que je vis sur la
terre je n'ai pas perdu sur la terre
change de planète est pas perdue dans
exactement
ouais ouais bah t'es quoi eh ben on va
et je te jure que je vais répéter un
truc parce que je pense que ce serait
vraiment génial et avec toi je pense
qu'on pourrait on pourrait rigoler tous
les ballons pour rigoler mais surtout tu
je pense que je vais j'y vais pas rester
longtemps